[Music]
oh crap
hi hello i'm christian shafer i'm an
outdoor adventure photographer and i've
been living on the road for almost four
years it'll be four years this may i
started out in my suv i lived there for
14 months and then i transitioned into
this 60 square foot van which i've
called home now for just over two and a
half years there's a lot of content out
there that creates this unrealistic
expectation of beautiful views and
never-ending adventure i definitely
contribute to a lot of that content i
really like to focus on the positives
because i personally love this lifestyle
that said this lifestyle is by no means
easy it is challenging it is not for
everyone
and that's why i want to make this video
let's begin with overnight parking which
sometimes is difficult to find
especially on travel days or times where
i'm waiting on a shipment i need to be
somewhat near a city and that can limit
my camping options sometimes that means
i'm camping at a walmart or stealth
camping on the street or i'm having to
drive long distances from my campsite
into the city so that i can run errands
there are a lot of places that highly
discourage if not criminalized vehicle
dwelling which means you need to
familiarize yourself with local laws
whenever you travel someplace new and of
course there's always the possibility
that you might get that dreaded knock
from a cop in the middle of the night
which
knock on wood has never actually
happened to me but i know that it does
if you're in the middle of nowhere you
might be more exposed you might have
fewer amenities such as a shower or the
ability to restock essentials like water
food and gas generally speaking you're
always on the hunt for a place that
meets a few different criteria you want
it to be safe legal accessible flat it'd
be great if had cell service hopefully
it's somewhat quiet and if you're lucky
you might get a beautiful view okay
so
head needs to go in one of those corners
and now
okay head needs to go in that corner
and that's
how i work out which way to sleep every
night the bed is six feet across and i'm
only five nine so i do fit but i like to
spread out so when i sleep diagonal you
get six foot three foot of space so
that's my preferred way of sleeping or i
can level out the van using our v blocks
but that isn't something i would do in
an urban location because it pretty much
shouts that you're sleeping in there
also it was far easier to park overnight
in my suv than it is in the van because
the suv had more of a stealth factor and
it was also 4x4 so i could get to remote
camping spots that my van just can't
reach now that i have the van i tend to
scout with my drone for open campsites
before driving down roads where i might
get stuck
as far as safety goes i did a whole
video on that which i will link up here
if you want to check that out but that
is an important part of finding a
quality campsite space okay so this van
is 60 square feet and i have no idea
what my suv was but it was way smaller
than this which means there's only so
much space everything has a home and
things can get really messy really fast
living like this tends to create one of
two scenarios you either become really
clean and organized or really messy
having less space means i have less room
for luxuries like a full bathroom or a
shower or a dedicated workspace or a
garage where i could store something
like a bike or a surfboard i can only
have so many clothes or shoes or camping
gear and fitting it all in starts to
feel like a never ending game of tetris
i also have storage for just 10 gallons
of water and my fridge and cupboards are
small which means i have to pass through
cities on a more regular basis to
resupply also side note this van was
built for one person two people in here
would not be very comfortable nathaniel
and i have our own separate rigs and
that works well for us shower and
bathroom i do not have a shower or a
composting toilet in my van i do however
have a cassette toilet but it's for
number one only which means i'm always
planning my route according to gyms
campgrounds and other places where i can
comfortably shower and use the restroom
most of the time i'm camping in remote
locations where i can use a solar shower
and use the bathroom in the same way i
would when tent camping using a shovel
during the summer when it's hot and i'm
hiking a lot i'm jumping into lakes and
rivers and i might not take an actual
shower for a week honestly this doesn't
even bother me at this point i've just
been doing it for so long that i'm i'm
just used to it but if you're
transitioning from a house into a van or
vehicle it's definitely annoying next is
lack of normalcy living out here on the
road you start to feel like you're
living on the fringe a little bit kind
of disconnected from society and
a little bit of an outcast add to this
lack of routine lack of community and
the occasional bout of loneliness and
the overall lack of normalcy can start
to take a toll on your mental health
always waking up somewhere new means
constantly navigating new roads and
familiarizing yourself with state laws
and local ordinances and overcoming
obstacles that
sometimes just really only happen on the
road so
today
has been super annoying nathaniel got a
mouse and his engine bay and then we
discovered
little nests all around where we were
parked mice can do a lot of damage so we
packed up everything in a hurry and we
left
and right as we were pulling out i
got pulled over i didn't know what the
speed limit was and
ended up going 10 over so that was
crappy and then we ended up driving for
a couple hours and sleeping in a walmart
parking lot which is always my favorite
and then this morning i discovered that
my cabinet up here this whole cabinet is
starting to fall like there's
almost half inch gap between the ceiling
and the cabinet so i'm at a home depot
now and yeah gotta
go buy some screws and cross my fingers
and hope i do this right this is van
life out here things rarely go as
planned and you have to be flexible in
order to be successful in this lifestyle
things like doctor and dentist
appointments or having a trusted car
mechanic that you always go to
or hairstylist that you love or
a local bakery that you love to stop by
because you know everyone that works
there those things kind of go out the
window when you live on the road
they're not impossible but they're just
they're more difficult because you don't
live there and you don't have the roots
in the community like you used to
same thing goes with just grabbing a
friend for lunch or
you know signing up for a weekly pottery
class in the town that you live in those
things are harder to do on the road and
one thing that i've learned
while being out here is to travel slow
so i try to spend two to four weeks in
every location
just because it helps me slow down it
helps me have a little bit of routine
and hopefully community even if it is
only temporary another thing i want to
mention is decision fatigue
every day on the road you have to make
some decision whether it's where to park
where to sleep how long to drive where
to go whether or not to shower where to
shower where to shop
and that can be exciting at first but
over time it can start to wear you out
because making all those decisions just
requires a lot of mental energy it is
the next day and officially five days
since my last shower
but we continue with legal stuff legal
stuff can be challenging while living on
the road our society doesn't really
cater to the nomadic lifestyle which
means you're left to figure out how to
have a mailing address how to actually
receive that mail while traveling how to
renew your driver's license vehicle
registration how to obtain vehicle
insurance how to insure the things in
your vehicle health insurance and of
course taxes
it's a lot and oftentimes it really just
depends on the state you reside in for
example in washington state it's legal
to live in your vehicle but that's not
true for every state
and for vehicle insurance i had to have
my van inspected and registered as an rv
in order to have it properly insured and
if on top of all that you're working
remotely and you're self-employed like i
am then you also have expenses to track
and taxes to file so thank you turbotax
for sponsoring this video i have
actually used turbotax for nearly a
decade so i was super stoked when they
reached out actually a big part of
living on the road full time is finding
a way to sustain this lifestyle which is
why i sometimes work with sponsors when
i create these videos but earning an
income is only part of the equation you
also need to track your finances budget
and pay taxes on those earnings with
turbo tax i'm able to have a hands-on
approach with my finances so that i have
a full understanding of what deductions
i qualify for what rate my income is
taxed at and how to set myself up for
success moving into the new tax year i
use the turbotax live self-employed
version which allows access to a live
tax expert who will give advice and
answer questions as you go and for me
this has made the process of filing
taxes so much easier after uploading my
tax forms an expert was able to walk me
through a few different questions and
tax scenarios over the phone which was
super helpful and saved me a lot of time
and research
turbo tax experts help you find every
possible tax deduction and credit and
you can connect with them as often as
you need throughout the tax year i
recently jotted down a few new questions
around reporting crypto earnings and
investments and it's nice knowing that i
can reach out and get answers all from
the comfort of my own van
they also do a final expert review just
so you have peace of mind that your
taxes are done right and if you use my
link below you can save up to 15 off
your purchase with turbo tax
lack of convenience
ventures can be a total time suck in a
house you just walk over to your shower
and take a shower when i want to shower
i have to drive to the gym or campground
you probably don't have to convert your
bed into a living space every morning
like i do and you likely have endless
hot water and soap whenever you do your
dishes
i used to be able to throw my laundry in
the wash and then switch it over when i
got home now i have to find a laundromat
and hang around while i wait for my
clothes to wash and dry i fill my water
tanks once a week switch out my propane
tank pretty often find places to empty
trash empty my toilet empty my gray
water take go grocery shopping i don't
have a freezer and i can't buy anything
in bulk i don't have an oven or closet
where i can hang my clothes so they're
pretty much always wrinkly and mail
packages aren't delivered to my doorstep
so basically everything just takes
longer
and i'm pretty much always at the mercy
of the weather if it's too hot or too
cold i relocate if it's raining or
cloudy and there isn't enough sunshine
for my solar panels i relocate
it's frozen planning things can be
difficult and sometimes i just really
miss having a home to go back to and
relax and not have to think about all
the things that van life requires lack
of privacy you're pretty much always on
display when you live in your vehicle
unless you're always hiding inside your
rig or parked someplace remote people
can see you when you're cooking food
outside or filling your water or
whatever chores you need to do
if you don't have a full bathroom you're
showering and using the restroom in a
lot of public places if you're hanging
around cities you're dealing with the
sounds of cars driving by garbage trucks
or car doors shutting
oh my god
the sound of cars and people are
starting to drive me insane if i'm being
really honest people are pretty much
always walking around you and sometimes
they might even peer into your windows
actually that happens to me kind of
often i think people are just curious
but it can be weird sometimes like they
don't even see me even though i'm
literally sitting at my desk working and
i can pretty much guarantee that if i
leave my side door open for more than
five minutes in a public place someone
will start asking me questions or want a
tour and look i think that's great i
mean before i had a van i was that
person i was constantly curious if i saw
another van lifer i'd be like asking all
the questions and i'd want a tour so i
get it it's just when you do this full
time
and say you're in a hurry or you're
trying to get through a to-do list or
you just don't want to talk to anyone it
can start to feel like an invasion of
privacy i mean imagine in your house
every time that you walk outside if
someone's just passing by on the
sidewalk and they stop and say wow your
house looks really cool can i come
inside and you just being like sure come
on in but that's the kind of thing
you're really opening yourself up to
when you live on the road i think if
you're an extrovert or craving social
interaction this is no problem at all in
fact it's a great conversation starter
and i've met a lot of cool people this
way but if you're an introvert like me
it might push your limits over time mail
and shipping so this one is actually a
huge headache for me i would have made
it number one but i think it's probably
not that big of a deal for most road
lifers but with the kind of work that i
do i have to be able to receive products
on a really regular basis in order to
shoot upcoming brand campaigns so that
means i'm typically hanging around
cities way more than i want to sometimes
i get stuck in a place waiting on a
package sometimes the package never
shows up or is sent back for unknown
reasons and other times a package will
arrive well after i've left and i have
to either backtrack or just let it go
when they do arrive my next task is
usually to hunt down public recycling
bins that are legal to use or else my
van can turn into a trash bin real fast
i have a private mailbox in washington
and i forward mail from there pretty
often so i don't miss important
documents like toll fees client checks
or jury duty summons if you're
interested in learning more about this
specifically i will link a video i did
up here about a day in the life and how
i get mail wi-fi this is another one
that is uniquely frustrating if you are
working remotely i have left many a
great campsite because i was pulling out
my hair over getting a signal if your
goal is to relax and be off the grid
this isn't such a big deal
but when you need internet for work
hunting down a solid signal can become a
huge time suck
a lot of times this might mean hanging
around cities more than you want to or
investing in a wi-fi device or a signal
booster i also have a video on how i get
wi-fi and i will link that up here if
you want to check it out breakdowns and
unexpected maintenance costs i don't
have any mechanical skills and i need
this vehicle to be reliable for work
assignments so that's the main reason i
bought a new van that said i've got 37
000 miles on the van now and no doubt
i'll have some maintenance coming up the
only issues i've had so far are a
cracked windshield needing to replace
the tires and a weird mirror issue that
was finally solved after tracing it back
to a pinched wire other than that this
van has been
super solid the build itself is starting
to show somewhere and tear especially in
the last six months i've had to do some
maintenance here and there but i suspect
it will need some major upgrades in the
next year or so that said i do take
really good care of this fan by keeping
it clean and staying on top of minor
repairs and that does require time and
energy on a regular basis
also living in a vehicle especially in
remote locations or means that you're
often parking your entire home in places
that are home to mice and spiders and
all kinds of creatures mice can do some
pretty serious damage to your electrical
wiring once they get in and spiders
okay that cannot stay in the van
last month i had a couple spiders wander
indoors and since then i've been using
peppermint spray which seems to be
working so far i also use a bear bin to
store my trash away from my vehicle when
i'm camped in remote locations for long
periods of time and that definitely
seems to help okay that was a lot
hopefully i managed to convince you all
that van life sucks i'm totally kidding
if you know me at all then you know i
love this lifestyle this may will
actually be four years of being on the
road and despite all of these challenges
i stay out here i really value the
freedom to travel and be outdoors and
meet new people and experience things i
might otherwise miss
here on the road there's solitude and
beautiful views and a chance to escape
all the noise of cities in constant
motion and just slow down and allow
myself to explore and create and live
life on my own terms if after all this
you're still interested in van life you
can check out my video on how to get
started i'll link it up here i walk you
through practical steps on what it
really takes to downsize plan and adapt
to life on the road one thing i
mentioned in there is that i started
living out of my suv as an experiment it
wasn't meant to be permanent so i had
very low expectations and because of
that i found it to be much better than i
imagined and when i finally upgraded to
a van it felt like a mansion compared to
an suv so i think those transitional
steps help me adapt to this way of
living in a very realistic way which is
something you might consider yourselves
before investing in an expensive setup
and that's about it thanks for sticking
around i know this was kind of a long
one i appreciate you guys being here and
i guess i'll catch you in the next one
or in the meantime you can find me over
on instagram at christianchafer
[Music]